how you feel you know I humiliate it hey
there
I'm aria and I've often abused
BuzzFeed's resources to try and find
myself love so this new year I've
decided to give back I'm gonna start by
helping my best bud Nando find love
through using wikiHow tutorials to help
him create the perfect online dating
profile wikiHow is an online database of
tutorials ranging from the mundane to
the outright bizarre with an entire
section devoted to relationships I
figured we try a few guides to see if
any can help out Fernando I'm really
hung over
you see Nando hasn't been in a
relationship for almost a year and is
now looking for something serious I
wanted a date last night how did the day
go and before you're asking is if I
ejaculated no I did it yeah but my love
life right now it's actually pretty cold
you only had 108 110 a day well then
perfect cuz we got all these documents
from wikiHow about how to basically
succeed at online dating how to write a
captivating online dating profile I
don't have one my nothing give them
higher I got recommended by our legal
rep Rebecca Megan I'm have you dabbled
in there cold yes okay recommend a great
dating site that she thinks would be
good for you called farmers only you
love country boys somebody from a dairy
I would like that has sex on like a bed
of cheese
to assist us we also rope enjoys
BuzzFeed's resident love guru remember
that when creating a profile less is
more does it keep it real do you believe
in that most sites also offer a heading
catchphrase size tagline that appeared
in the searches just drop people into
your profile humor often works best time
eeeh
love me like a cattle ride me I like
that I'm just giving them a just sexy
like oh you're scared of that cuz you
just said you want love what do you want
Fernando if you're gonna come into my
office tell me what you really want boy
I want love but I also want to come okay
don't buy this cattle Moo my I like
Bomar Oh a sexually mature male bovine
that's kind of like you so make a home I
like that show people your personality
don't describe it I think we should talk
about my favorite type of cheese okay so
that's cool cuz we got it right here
daddy are you coming young raging boy
looking for the one so I could ride that
saddle till the Sun comes up yeah now
they say the next step is of course
choose a photo more than one photo
allows for people to get a more
3-dimensional idea of what you look like
in different contexts preferably include
at least one head shot on one full body
shot let's keep in mind this is for
farmersonly.com so we're playing to a
market take your shirt off
put this on put that under the vest no
no we need to show the skin we have to
make it look like he's out in the
country yeah
there that looks like a farm you could
find that in a farm trash kid thumbs
like here that's a country boy thing
the original and grab people's attention
to receive high responses for example
you could put one where you draw a
smiley face on a piece of paper and
cover your face with it these kinds of
pictures will add a touch of perky
playfulness and while adding a sense of
mystery that people want more I see
someone with a like single smiley face
I'm gonna think they're a mass-murderer
nobody's responded no one's responded
yet but there was one final wikiHow guy
that i found that i think is the best
way to end this day how to cast a love
spell and so we will be doing that right
here in the bathtub
yeah like with water in it yeah and you
know now you serious right negativity is
washed away and renewed as off today
many heads will turn my way the ones I
choose will wish to stay relaxed to
focus on your body as you anticipate
after the water think and feel how
sensual it is and how beautiful you are
you're thinking those things turn off
the lights and turn on your favorite
music choose music that's in line with
your desired end result so what type of
music do you are you feeling I'm feeling
like a funky ballet almost
enter the bath and relax make sure every
part of your body is immersed in the
water at least once
[Music]
I am loving I am loved and loved myself
and I am loved
[Music]
sure check the website this spell is
very basic if you like someone wiper
what does it over I do know many other
people in my life needs everything to
really love myself sound care if the bad
listen to good music I do that once a
week with a lot of the lion yeah I'm
still single
how do you feel how much after this and
you recording them every session you
know for me I'm just really happy that I
got to hang out with you guys and you
believe in love and we followed it we
follow the look love at the end of the
day is a good thing it is don't do it
like this but not only will find it
[Music]
[Music]